all right everybody we got this first
story here from uh the quartering this
is Jeremy Hambly and I'll show you a few
of these uh stories Jeremy tweeted six
hours ago this is some bull-ish it says
the video has been removed for violating
YouTube's policy on harassment and
bullying he says this is an escalation
of something I've been noticing in
analytics this is why the Publican now
was started I'll make a video now but
consider joining today and then he says
it was a video where I defended Dylan
Mulvaney much to the Chagrin of many for
how mean Matt Walsh was to him I now
regret that and then we have uh this
from Sydney Watson it says YouTube has
deleted an entire video from the
quartering and my community community
notes channel for bullying and
harassment we have to assume it's
because we discussed Dylan Mulvaney this
is exactly why we created the public a
noun and why we are so appreciative of
everyone who has signed up as a member
to support the effort gender ideology is
a Scourge and it's asinine we can't call
it out
so I can only imagine this will continue
to get worse in terms of The Purge and
uh Liz you you were just mentioning you
had videos taken down as well yeah yeah
yeah I did and it was about these same
topics like I said I'm not surprised
here I don't think any of us think of
ourselves as victims here but it is
quite something to see the censorship
and what discussion the left and these
these these corporate overlords don't
want us to be having does it ever
resemble what you experience working in
cable you should do a cable TV TV show
right I did no it's it's pretty
different in a cable news setting I had
actually a tremendous amount of freedom
and didn't really have restrictions on
what I could say it was before it was
largely before a lot of the transgender
conversations it's funny actually a
little detour here there was a video of
mine that that went viral it was from
five or six years ago when I was talking
about like what's the limiting principle
so when Tommy Lee posted
um and it I was talking about well
what's the limiting principle on
transgender
this video went pretty viral even though
it was from a few years ago and I
remember the day that I made that
because the crew that day were like okay
that's a little hyperbolic don't you
think and it's all happening now
um but at the time there wasn't the
censorship because The Descent against
it was just not quite hadn't quite
ramped up hadn't built up to the point
that we're at now
um so very different very different to
be independent it's fun to be
independent it's fun to own your own
company and to build your own to build
your own thing it does make it trickier
from a business aspect when you have to
dodge these kind of bullets but I care
less about the business aspect of it and
more about like the mission at part of
it we talk about this stuff because we
care about these people right not
necessarily not because it's good clicks
I think this may have something to do
with Anheuser-Busch the uh the removal
of the content and it's a convenient
scapegoat for YouTube to go after
um like harassment and bullying because
it's clearly related to Matt Walsh Dylan
Mulvaney these are these are some of the
the issues surrounding the the video
that Matt Walsh uh what triggered it all
was when he was critical of Dylan
Mulvaney which resulted in people
responding saying you maybe pushed it
too far Matt you're a little mean but
that's all he was he was mean to a
person and I think the issue is
well let me put it this way
YouTube didn't say anything
this story came and went this was months
ago the story came and went but only now
that the Anheuser-Busch hit has extended
into now I think we're going to be
entering soon a fourth week this is the
end of I think the third week of
Anheuser-Busch boycott getting worse new
reporting that their sales are
continuing to drop there they've started
doing I've started getting ads from
Budweiser for the first time ever and so
what I think is happening is my personal
opinion here is that Anheuser-Busch
contacted YouTube and said it's your
fault and if you don't take this down we
will stop advertising With You YouTube
then says okay what do we do there are
big advertisers the biggest beer brand
in the world let's start removing these
videos I'm willing to bet Anheuser-Busch
went to YouTube a while ago and again
just my personal opinion I don't have
any Insider information or anything like
that I bet they went to YouTube and said
we spend too much money on your platform
to have to deal with all of these
channels using that platform to hurt us
so we're gonna stop buying from you it
probably took YouTube a little while to
come up with a plan so this this to me I
think Anheuser-Busch probably went to
YouTube a week and a half ago saying
look at all these videos we're spending
X dollars but all these videos keep
coming out so YouTube probably came up
with the policy they probably discussion
where they said look if we ban these
videos and give strikes we're gonna lose
way more money the the videos don't
break the rules you know how I know they
don't break the rules YouTube did not
give strikes to any of these channels
that's very weird this first time I've
heard of that so when we got two videos
taken down they say we're just removing
them but you're not getting a strike we
got a strike I think you got a strike
yeah we gotta strike so uh I think
Jeremy said he didn't get a strike
either right I don't know that they just
removed it oh actually I have to I'm
gonna double check but I'm pretty sure
we got a strike look look here's here's
what Sydney Watson posted it says we
want to let you know our team reviewed
your content and we think it violates
our harassment policy we know you may
not have real lives was a violation of
our policy so we're not applying a
strike to your channel what that says to
me again in my personal opinion is that
they know it doesn't really break the
rules and if they apply a strike they
will lose more money the verbiage is we
think you violated it like it should
just say if we think it violates our we
think it did but we don't know you
didn't know it's illegal protection yeah
I understand mine says we think I'm
looking it up right now it says we think
it violates so we're going to approach
no we did get a strike it says we think
the notice so the email that I got
that's what I have a copy of right here
can you read that paragraph yeah says
our team has reviewed your content
unfortunately we think it violates our
hate speech policy we removed the
following content from YouTube we got
two emails oh no my team just texted me
we definitely got a strike oh wow but
they're saying hate speech in yours yeah
they defined hate speech and they said
we got an email that said exactly the
phrase that I used that they consider to
be hate speech well don't say yeah
why is yours hate speech and this one is
harassment different things were said
but but here's by the way it's not hate
speech like what it's a bad term these
days that's really freaky this is
important though
here's here's why I think this YouTube
probably sat down and said if we apply a
strike to timcast IRL how much money do
we lose all of it we would leave the
network I mean it's not it's not just
the advertising it's not just the super
chats it's that the consistently highest
viewed uh like nightly show on YouTube
will immediately switch to rumble so
we're going to lose long-term Revenue
we're going to lose market share we're
gonna lose direct advertising what can
we do Budweiser Anheuser bush is furious
and we're going to lose their ads how
about we just take those videos down
from all these channels and then just
sweep it under the rug and don't apply
the strikes where we where we can avoid
applying strikes if you give a live show
a strike there's no live show so that's
why I think they're like okay let's just
take them down and not do a strike
because we want to make money this says
to me strictly about advertising and I
think Anheuser-Busch behind the scenes
is screaming but they know they can't
say things publicly they have dumped
money into this ad about this this
Clydesdale running streets or whatever
and it's because they did this after 9
11 and everybody loved it the Clydesdale
after 9 11 was a big deal they're trying
to do it again they are desperate their
sales are apparently down like 10 in the
first two days of the boycott so we have
not yet gotten the data from
Anheuser-Busch on the past couple of
weeks but I bet it's so bad they went to
YouTube and said why should we advertise
with you when you keep publishing the
smears against us
when you're navigating these
conversations in my experience like
transgenderism for instance which isn't
it's a very important conversation for
everybody people that are transgender
that aren't transgender people we need
to communicate and find some common
ground there's you go the route of
talking you know systemically about
transgenderism and what you know body
dysmorphia and things like that then
there's that's one path then the other
path is you talk about
sexualizing children which is a
completely different conversation you
could be a straight person that's doing
it a transgender person that's doing it
that's another conversation when
children are involved then there's a
third part of it which is targeting
people like how Dylan got his name
brought up and I'm not I I like I mean
whatever you know Dylan you know I like
it but when people bring up specific
people over and over again then it
starts to be like dog piling and they're
like do you consider harassment I'm
sorry can you harass the president by
criticizing things they do publicly it's
also not an individual I mean obviously
Dylan is an individual person but he's
also a very very influential
um activist political activist and
public figure right I mean there's
certain not just don't look bigger but
an actual political activist who went to
the White House to try to get policy
passed about what state right but what
I'm saying is libel law is different for
public figure
so you know I think because we have
access to the internet and potentially
going viral basically in our pocket at
all times with our phones people forget
that you are electing to become a public
figure and therefore you are losing some
of your legal protections and the
squeaky wheel gets the grease but I
think I think this is a more
Anheuser-Busch and the evidence of that
is there's been conversation around
Dylan mulvanio's 11 million followers
for a very long time over a year that's
the you know we're on uh date year two
of the days of girlhood saga that Dylan
Mulvaney has produced you did didn't
care
until Anheuser-Busch a major Advertiser
started getting hit in the market share
and losing sales so it it there actually
is a reasonable business like capitalist
response Anheuser Bush might have just
been like we're not telling you YouTube
like they might have been like YouTube
we're not telling you to do anything
we're just pointing out there's really
no reason for us to advertising your
platform everybody hates us there so bye
it could be more than in bed because
Dylan has uh marketing sponsorships with
lots of different companies Crest uh
CeraVe EOS
they may have but but his agent may have
gone to all his people and be like let's
do a combined uh communication with
YouTube that we will all leave the
network like Crest would leave Budweiser
would leave and so YouTube's like well
I wonder who is uh backing his his legal
defense fund right because I can imagine
just like Anheuser-Busch would go after
YouTube I assume Dylan also has a legal
team that's trying to get it and also
this is possible don't forget about the
corporate equality index you know that
that organization that's from the human
rights campaign that goes around it's
part of like the ESG metrics but it's
specifically focused on ranking whether
these big corporations are lgbtq
friendly quote unquote places to work
and they send representatives to these
corporations to make sure not just not
just for uh privileges or actual
workplace environment but whether these
corporations are doing advertising
campaigns that are specifically quote
unquote inclusive of transgender people
so I think that there's a lot of power
right now behind
um behind making sure that
Anheuser-Busch doesn't back down
especially as they're realizing that
this boycott is real a lot of
conservative boycotts yeah and azerbush
apologizes yes yes because maybe I mean
I don't think they probably would have
but I think that they underestimated the
strength of this boycott because a lot
of conservative boycotts in the past
have been like fleeting they haven't
been incredibly effective
um because a lot of people don't agree
but this one's very effective but it
goes beyond this because uh and I'll
throw to Jesse Kelly I mentioned I cited
him several times he said it's the first
time his neighbors asked him about
politics yeah
yeah and I've actually heard
surprisingly you try to talk to people
about politics you know how it goes and
they're gonna be like oh you're talking
about now I'm out and people are like oh
that Bud Light thing and they they know
about it thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time